(audience cheering)
- All right, we've got an
incredible feel good story
to close out this hour.
This is what I'm liking.
(cheerful upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
About a week ago, a
Florida woman was driving
on a busy road when she
had a medical incident
and passed out behind
the wheel, super scary.
Amazingly her coworker, Janet,
who was also in a nearby car,
saw what was going on
and sprung into action.
As you can see, she got
on foot racing through
the bustling intersection
and waving her arms
to get other drivers' attention.
Soon, strangers were
getting out of their cars
to stop the moving vehicle.
It's amazing how many people came together
to protect this woman and
everyone else around them.
We have Janet and her coworker,
Lori, on the line right now.
So they're watching on
WP TV West Palm Beach.
What's up, y'all?
(audience cheering)
- Hi, Kelly. (chuckles)
- Hi.
Lori, first of all, I'm glad
to see that you're all right.
You feeling good?
- Thank you, I feel great.
- I've never seen anything
like that on video.
I was like, "Wait, what?"
So Janet it's lucky that
you saw what was going on.
So tell us what you remember.
- We worked together and we
never could be in the same role
in the same time and this time we did.
And when I saw her hitting the sidewalk
she went to the second
lane and then I see her
going that way and I'm like,
"Something's wrong with her."
And then I'm like, "Oh, this isn't her."
So I went and I parked my
car and I start running,
banging the window to
see if she would respond,
but she didn't respond at the minute.
But then I'm waving my
hands and I am saying
"Help, help, help" and
then more people came over
and tried to help me.
- Oh my gosh, it's the craziest footage.
And it's so amazing how
everyone came together.
But Janet, Lori, you've since met
with some of the other
good Samaritans, right?
- Oh yes. That was wonderful.
They had a nice celebration
at the police department
and we all got together
and it was just wonderful
to see everyone and to get to know them.
We're all gonna have dinner
and we're gonna get together again.
It was just wonderful
to meet all these people
and to say thank you to them all.
- Absolutely. Well,
thank you so much, Janet.
Thank you so much, Lori.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(audience cheering)
And that's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of Friction, the go to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
they think Janet's actions
were as fearless as we do.
So Janet, they're gonna give
you $1000 just for being rad.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Absolutely. All
right, thank you guys so much.